says that criminals have no
rights But why is the focus
always on the rights of
criminals and the vast majority of
honest people
[Music]
crang I think that Human Rights siad
doubts that prisoners have
human rights but I think that something  that has not been
done and no attorney has done it
before or at least I don't remember.
Excuse me if you did it and I don't
remember, but they haven't defended the
human rights of honest people.
Generally, they defend, as it were, the entire
Human Rights approach.  Human
international or NGOs are even
focused on the rights of
criminals who have rights, no one
says that criminals do not have
rights But why is the focus
always on the rights of
criminals and the vast majority of
honest people, no one cares  their rights
in this country we spent 30 years being
shot down murdered rented raped extorted threatened
and
living in their works and no one said anything
but suddenly they catch those who kill those
who rent those who violate and
suddenly we have to look at human rights
Of them they will have human rights
but the
human rights of honest people are more important and
I think that is something important,
attorney that must also investigate
and must also report because if not
then we are not talking about
Human Rights, we are talking about the rights of
the  criminals that I think are two
different things human rights are
all and the rights that and the people
who do not have their rights restricted
are the honest people because the
others have human rights but
they have restricted rights for example they
do not have the right to vote they do not have the
right  to economic activity they do not
have the right to freedom Why they
committed a crime So if they are
restricted in the United States some do not
have the right to life because they are
put in the electric chair So if
some
human rights as fundamental as the
right can be restricted  to life in the case of
countries that have the death penalty, why
in the case of poor countries or in the
case of developing countries in
the Third World it is clear that
criminals should have rights
but when we talk about  the rights of
the population there, everyone remains
silent and it no longer matters and what
we have to do is continue to ensure
the rights of criminals.
So while we are going to
respect the rights of criminals
and we are doing it and we have  been
doing all this time but our
priority is going to be the rights of the
honest population who are those who do not
have their right because noer those of
listening On A podcast Who Don't speak
English he basically said is wrong That
Was the thrust of it  the thrust of It is
stop as San societies caring about
people who don't care about treating
ille as
If moreth resource and Everything Else
then the legal people who are in these
countries paying taxes doing the right
Thing How about you Start All of Us
whether  It's down in El Salvador It's
here in the United States or It's Across
the pond in the UK How about Start
caring about the people who are in your
civilizations Who have built your
culture and built your buildings and
built your societies and expanded more
freedoms than you  can possibly Freak and
Imagine Imagine If government started
working for Those people instead of
having people like perm jaap who's
mostly concerned that we're Calling
illegal people
illegal